It's great to welcome to the program today.
Adrian Baaden, who is professor of philosophy
at Wake Forest University and also author
of the book The Truth About Denial, Bias and
Self-deception in Science, Politics and Religion.
It's really great to have you on.
I appreciate it.
Hey, David.
Thanks for having me.
So to start with denialism, how far back does
denialism go as far as we know?
I mean, were there early denial lists when
there were the original theories about what
are humans and what is outer space and is
whether God or simply the machinations of
climate or I mean, like how far back does
denialism go in some way, shape or form?
Well, well, yes.
All of the all of the above.
I would I would send it back several million
years, as a matter of fact.
So so Homo sapiens evolved in small groups
and going back further to our ancestors.
They were in the same situation.
And.
The it's a really important adaptive trait.
If you're living in a small room to be able
to integrate yourself into the group's ideological
worldview, you know, if your group worships
Poseidon, you better figure out a way to believe
in Poseidon.
Otherwise, you're out.
For example.
Right.
So it's really deep, deep in our evolutionary
history that we have formed this talent for
rationalizing beliefs and our beliefs in order
to integrate with a with a larger worldview.
So, yes.
And so then that moves forward through history,
all kinds of religious beliefs, obviously.
That's probably the beginning of it all.
Beliefs about other groups.
Because what are our evolutionary context
was we evolved in small groups that were in
competition with other groups.
So if we hate the group, if you know, if our
group hates the group across the river, I'm
going to find reasons to hate that group,
too.
Otherwise, I'm not able to integrate myself
into my own group because we don't we don't
survive well on our own cooperation, social
cooperation.
That's our evolutionary niche.
That's that's that's what gives us our advantage.
That's interesting.
So early on, there was an evolutionarily advantageous
reason why we were able to sort of potentially
suppress contradictory information in order
to be in line with with our group.
Does that still hold true today in the same
way?
I mean, is it an issue of evolutionary advantage
at this point?
Well, it's well, a lot of things that in the
past were an advantage aren't necessarily
an advantage now, but it's still there.
It's real deep, so deep in our cognitive makeup
that we we have these skills.
We're actually very, very good at adapting
our beliefs, not just our behavior, but our
beliefs to our situation.
And you mentioned, you know, ignoring evidence
or picking out the evidence that you want,
rationalizing what's called confirmation bias.
Right.
You ignore the evidence you don't want and
you seek out evidence or reasons to believe
what you want to believe anyway.
And that becomes actually particularly toxic
in our current media environment, where you
can go wherever you want to to get the world
view that that you want to believe.
And you get the picture of the world presented
to you in in, you know, HD video and describe
to you the way you want to hear it.
And it you know.
And so we have.
But you know what's called these, you know,
media bubbles that people get into in addition
to things like our geographic sorting here
in the United States in particular, peoples
have sorted themselves very well geographically
into like minded communities.
Is there any demographic trends that you see
in terms of denialism and and sort of rejection
of disconfirms confirmatory evidence, maybe
like in terms of age?
Is there a certain age at which this becomes
more prevalent?
And if so, is is that an education or a cultural
thing or anything demographically that you've
observed?
Well, you'll you'll hear different theories
from different social scientists about this.
Younger people have demonstrated a little
more cognitive flexibility and openness.
Older folks are, as you would say, you know,
are more set in their ways.
They're also a little more sensitive to threat.
They feel more threatened.
And that's a really big factor here.
If we also look at the progressive slash liberal
versus conservative ways of thinking about
the world.
So where conservatives and conservatives obviously
skew at this point in the US wider and older,
obviously conservatives by definition are
what we call system justifier.
They are pro status quo.
Conservatives are comfortable with the way
things are in terms of the social and economic
order and its hierarchies.
And they will they will seek out reasons to
dismiss evidence that there's something wrong
with that order, such as, you know, systemic
inequality and and younger people are less
prone to do that.
So it seems like there's an asymmetry there
in the sense that when you talk about the
status quo and you think about inertia, certainly
it takes less energy to maintain the status
quo in general.
All else being equal than it would to change
the status quo.
And so there is a sort of it seems that there
would be a structural advantage to those who
are predisposed to keep things the same, because
it's easier to do so in a sense.
Well, the status quo is upheld by all kinds
of systems.
For example, the police and the police are
the in any society, the police are the tip
of the spear when it comes to maintaining
the social and economic hierarchy.
That's what they're.
That's when we say law and order.
That's what the order part of that means.
You know, when Trump calls himself city law
and Nixon calls himself the law and Order,
President Trump calls himself the law and
order president.
That's what the order is.
The order is maintaining the kurk current
social and economic hierarchy.
And that includes, obviously, systems of systemic
racial bias and and systemic in structural
economic inequality.
I'm interested in climate change in this context
because we could think about a way in which
denying climate change goes against the known
facts and may be advantageous if you're part
of certain political groups.
Right.
So in order to keep the peace, as you suggest,
we may have this tendency to say, hey, let's
I'm going to even if there is information
that suggests climate change is real and it's
manmade, I'm going to stick with my group.
But over the long term, if it's true what
science says about the climate, it's self-destructive
to the human race and to the planet.
So it seems that there is a long term dis
advantage when it comes to the sort of evolutionary
aspect of it.
How could how should we interpret climate
change, that denial in this context?
David, I'm very interested in climate change
denial.
So I'm glad you bring it out.
The first thing I'd want to stress is that
being a climate science denier list has nothing
to do with being stupid or being uneducated.
In fact, what we see is the reverse.
If you're if you're a conservative, you're
more likely to be a climate science denier.
If you have a college education.
You're more likely when you give people tests
not just on science literacy, but climate
science literacy, you're more likely to be
a denier if you're conservative.
When you score higher on climate science literacy
tests.
So what does that telling us that telling
us is that we.
We are really good at rationalizing our own
beliefs.
The more information we have, the more ammunition
we get to rationalize those beliefs.
This puts us in a classic game, theoretical
situation.
I don't know if I want to get too technical
on this, but yeah, where individual decisions
about what's best for them in terms of what
belief systems they want to hold on to become
collectively absolutely disastrous in the
long run.
So that's interesting.
So.
So in other words, the the more information
we have, maybe not the more that our beliefs
align with what we would call an empirical
reality.
But the better we are at justifying the beliefs
that we have.
Well, we have more capacity to rationalize.
It doesn't mean we have to, but there is definitely
a tendency to do so.
I mean, we love to think of ourselves as these
purely rational beings, and all our beliefs
are based on evidence and listening to qualified
experts.
But in practice, that's not what happens when
there when it's beliefs, when when we're presented
with facts that are threatening to us.
So our our our very sense of identity is based
on the groups that we feel associated with
our.
Like I said, if I said, David, David, tell
me about yourself.
Right.
And I'm going to I'm going to make up some
things about you.
So I say, hey, David, tell me about yourself.
Who are you?
And you'd say, well, like, well, you know,
I was I was born in Rhode Island, but I grew
up in Texas.
My parents immigrated from Ireland.
I'm a Methodist.
I'm a social conservative.
But I feel strongly about the environment
and all of those facts that when you tell
me all about yourself, all of those things
are are relations.
You have two other groups.
And in terms of their ideological worldview,
that's your identity.
So when you're presented with facts that challenge
the world views of the groups that you associated
with.
It feels like a personal attack.
You have an emotional response.
And our brains are totally set up to defend
themselves.
And we defend ourselves by through rationalize,
rationalization, confirmation bias, what we
call motivated reasoning.
You have a conclusion in mind.
There's no such thing as climate change.
And then you seek out reasons to believe that
and you discount the reasons you're given
to believe that there is climate change.
Right.
And once again, in our media environment,
you can always find what you're looking for
when you're looking for reasons to rationalize
your own belief system.
So that gets me to sort of the last major
thing I want to touch on, which is we've now
widely read and researched and and discovered
that just giving people more facts and data
is not very effective at changing minds.
In fact, they can do the opposite, as you
say.
People can see that as a threat and further
kind of plant their feet in where they are.
What are the more effective ways to get people
to reconsider their beliefs and to throw out
just a couple of things.
One debate that I've had with some people,
and Nathan Jay Robinson, when I spoke to him,
he felt very strongly that appealing to people
on the basis of their values and tying that
to the conclusion you want is not a good idea.
So, for example, like appealing to to fiscal
conservatives to end the death penalty on
the cost issue, when in reality that may not
be the primary reason I might want to end
the death penalty.
There's debate over whether that's a good
idea or a bad idea.
Ballpark.
For us, the best strategies for effectively
getting people to change their beliefs.
I agree with that.
There's a lot of talk about message framing,
basically marketing your message to your audience.
Frame it in their values, in terms of their
values.
Hey, you're a conservative.
Let's talk about conserving the environment,
right?
You're an evangelical.
Let's talk about caring for God's creation.
Maybe over the very long term with a lot of
interactions.
And if you put that all in the right context
for a long period of time, that could change
people's minds.
A few interactions along those lines.
It's like it's like what was that old king
who who took a sword and tried to stop the
waves from coming in?
Right.
It people have this lifetime of cultural identification
so that any identity that they're just going
to blow at that kind of intervention out of
the water.
I would I would say rather appeal to local
issues that are of local interests.
Right.
Talk about, OK, I was just reading about Miami
and the fact that Miami is there saltwater
intrusion into the freshwater supply.
And right now, everyone and everyone in southeast
Florida.
No matter what political persuasion you are,
really cares about having drinking water and
not having flooding.
All right.
So don't talk about climate change.
Don't talk about the evidence for climate
change.
Just say, OK, we've got a sea water problem
in our freshwater supply.
What do we do about that?
I would start there.
You know, you talk about, you know, in the
in the in the American West, talk about drought
in an agricultural community.
Right.
I would start there.
That's I'm afraid that's that's not that doesn't
take you all the way to the kind of global
systemic change that we really need.
But that's the beginning.
There's things you could do in K through 12
education with grudged science education that
I think would be much better.
Instead of teaching people science facts,
we should we should be teaching kids scientific
method, really focusing on that, about curiosity,
about debunking claims that are not well founded
and and educate, educate kids.
Mean that's a generational thing.
The thing about climate change is that we
don't really have time for that.
So it's an urgent crisis.
And I, I don't have the sort of magic bullet
in terms of a message or event or send up
this message.
Yeah.
And we're going to convert everybody, including
those people who are invested in the status
quo so heavily that they're going to discount
that evidence automatically.
It's tough, but certainly I agree that at
a systemic level, starting with media literacy
and critical thinking far earlier as well.
We are.
We are kind of it's a long game, but we are
sort of better, better setting up society
to think thinking that way.
The book is The Truth About Denial, Bias and
Self-deception in Science, Politics and Religion.
We've been speaking with the book's author,
Adrian Baaden, who's professor of philosophy
at Wake Forest University.
I really appreciate your time today.
Thanks so much.